1층 환기덕트 평면도 보시면은
변기 위에 이렇게
환풍기가 설치가 되어야 되는데 지금
설치가 안 돼 있고 아예 접혀
있습니다 아 그냥 설치를 안 했구나
어쩜 이상한데 해서 도면을 보니까
환풍기가 설치됐어야 되는데 그쪽
위치가 비어 있는 상태입니다 영업적인
확인했을 때는 8대가 설치되었다고
했는데
실제로 나오는 건 재개발이 안 나오고
있었습니다 세 개밖에 안 나왔어요
요금은
8대 분 비용이 나가고 있었습니다
[음악]
제가 오늘은 저희 빌딩 관리팀에
박정도 대리님을 모셨습니다
안녕하세요
건물 관리하는 것도 계속 옆에서
지켜보고 제 건물도 관리를 하고 있고
대리님이 오고 나서 완전 바뀌었어요
완전 바뀌고 비용도 많이 낮춰졌어요
원래 시세가이 정도 되나 보다 하고
이제 계속 비용도 내고 있었는데 그런
고정비용들도 좀 많이 낮추고
추가적으로 비용이 발생될 부분을 미리
좀
확인을 한 다음에 사전에 예방을
하거나 뭐 이런 경우가 되게 많이
생겨 가지고 그래서 최근에 지금 빌딩
관리한 거 중에 좀 이슈가 됐거나
이렇게 좀 개선했던 거 그런 것들을
좀 설명해 주면 좋을 것 같습니다
일단 가장 최근 거 먼저 설명을
드리겠습니다 어제 점검을 갔던
현장인데 여기는 신축 건물입니다
문에다가 기계실 출입 금지
표시를 붙여야 되는데
시공사에서는 이렇게 주의 표시가 아닌
느낌으로 부착을 했습니다 보통은
출입 금지 표시를 하게 되면 이런
식으로 하게 됩니다
그러네요 이런 것도 신경 못 쓰는
경우도 많네요 보면 여기 보시면은
주차실이라고 되어 있는게 그 주차기
아랫부분이어서 이렇게
표시가 되어 있으면 사람들이 그냥
들어갈 수 있기 때문에 위험하니까
표시해 놓고 잠금장치도 해놔야 되는데
지금도 안 돼 있는 상태입니다 그래서
또 시공사에 열쇠를 받은 다음에 또
잠금장치도 하고
출입 금지 안내표도 잘 보이게끔
표시를 해서 안전사고 예방을 해야 될
것 같습니다
여기가 1층 화장실
천장 점검구 부분인데
이게 보시면은 자바라라고
환풍기랑 연결되는 호스입니다
근데
원래는 1층 환기덕트 평면도 보시면은
변기 위에 이렇게
환풍기가 설치가 되어야 되는데 지금
설치가 안 돼 있고 아예 접혀
있습니다
이런 거를 건물주분들의
체크를 못 하시니까 또 공사를 하게
되면 또 감리하시는 분이 계시는데
그분들도 이거를 놓친 거고
이런 걸 발견을 못 했으면
요만큼 또 자재비라던가 그런게 또
손해를 보게 되고 실제로 시공도 안
된 거니까 아마 문제가 좀
크지 않나 싶습니다 이거를 확인
못했구나 이거 말고도
도면 보시게 되면은 내용이 다른게
많더라구요 여기
지상 2층
평면도를 보시게 되면
실제로는
변기가 하나 있고 이렇게
요런 네모로 설치가 되어 있는데
도면상에는 또 위치가 또 다르게 되어
있습니다이
부분은 건물주분한테
얘기를 들어보고 이게 아마 최신
도면을 받은 건데 설계가 변경됐을
가능성도 있긴 합니다
근데 만약 이게 최종 도면이고
도면대로 설계가 안 된 거면 문제가
커지게 되는 거죠
보통은 저렇게까지
도면이나 맞는지 확인하시는
건물주분들이 많이 없어요
감리자가 있는데도 불구하고 감리자도
사실 그렇게 가지고 있지는 않았는데
관리하시는 분들도 도면은 절대 안
봅니다
아 이걸 또 어떻게 찾아냈구나 제가
봤을 때 건물관리에 거의 천직인 거
같아요
관리자 쪽으로 천직인 것 같습니다
1층
화장실 스위치
스위치를 보게 되면은 스위치는 두
개인데 하나를 눌렀을 때는 전등이
꺼졌다 켜졌다 하고 하나는 반응이
없어서
화장실 내부에 펜이 뭐 숨겨져 있을
수도 있다 생각을 해서
소리를 들어봤는데 아무런 소리도
안났습니다 좀 이상한데 해서 도면을
보니까
환풍기가 설치됐어야 되는데 그쪽
위치가 비어 있는 상태입니다
스위치가 환풍기 그 스위치인데 이거를
여분으로 만들어 두는 이런 거의 없고
근데 이제 그게 이제 작동이 안 돼서
보니까 설치가 알려
드렸어요
얘기는 들었습니다
심각한데
화장실인데 환풍기가 없게 되면
앞치라던가 또 그런 문제들이 또 크기
때문에 그 이런 경우엔 책임 소재가
좀 어떻게 되나요
시공사와 한번 협의를 해봐야 될 것
같습니다
그러니까 이거 우리가 관리하기
전까지는 몰랐잖아요 이게 지금 있는지
없는지 이거를 일반적인 건물
관리하시는 분들이
관리를 했으면 아마 놓쳤을 부분인데
그렇게 되면은
추후 한 4~5년 뒤에 이런게 발견이
되면은
책임 소재를 또 나누기가 힘드니까
초반에 발견을 했으면 뭐 고소를
한다던지이를 좀 크게 만들면은 건물
전체적으로 다시 하나하나 다 점검을
해달라고 요청을 할 예정입니다 지금
이거 말고도 건물에 하자가 많기
때문에 이런 거를 일을 크게 만들어서
전체적으로
점검을 요청해서 뭐 다른 하자들이 또
초반에 발견될 수 있게끔
진행하고 있습니다
옥상에 있는 등이
총 5개인데 그중에 두 개만 점등이
되고 있습니다
발견하기도 어렵고
점검 같은 경우는 저희가 낮에 하기
때문에 좀
발견하기 어려운 부분인데
당연히 신축인데 이런게 나갈 거라고
생각을 또 못 하시니까
설계사무소에서 전기를 되게 높게 잡아
놔 가지고 나한테
아니 이게
기본료가
110만원인가 나오더라고요이 건물
같은 경우
계약 전략이 150kw로 설정이 되어
있고
기본요금 계산은 1kw당 한
6천원으로 계산이 되어 있습니다
그렇게 따지면 기본요금만 90만원인데
지금 저희가 계약 전력을 오늘 변경
예정입니다
60kw로 낮추게 되면
그러면 기본요금이 36만원 정도가
되겠죠
그러니까
원래는 60만 해도 됐는데
150짜리를 만들어 놓은 거예요
150kw짜리를 만들어 놓고 그리고
기본료가 원래 90만원이었는데 이거를
내려 가지고 원래는 이제 30 몇
만원짜리가 붙어 있어야 되는데 저도
보면서 몇 달 냈잖아요 또 너무
아깝더라고 이게 미리 좀 체크가 된
다음에 건물에 맞게끔 이렇게 돼
있어야 되는데 너무 과도하게 이제
설치가 되어 있던 거죠 그것도 잘
찾아 가지고 이번에 내린 거 같아요
지금이 건물 같은 경우에는
지하 주차장
외부 쪽에 이렇게 배관이 설치가 되어
있기 때문에
동파 위험이 큽니다 그래서 최근에
동파도 됐었는데 여기 보시면 열선
같은게 다 있습니다
파란색은 수도 배관이고 노란색은 온수
배관인데 이것들이 작동이 안 돼서
배관이 좀 동파가 됐었습니다 보시면은
이렇게 다 덮어 놓은게 다
보온재입니다
열선을 넣고 또 보온재를 했는데 너무
추우니까 얼게 됩니다 영화 한 15도
이하로 떨어지게 되면 서서히 얼어
가지고 아
역류를 하게 돼요
여기 같은 경우는 리모델링 한지 한
3개월 정도 밖에 안 된 현장이기
때문에 열선이 설치됐는데도 열선이 또
미작동이어서 또 전원 코드가 분명히
차단기나 어딘가에 콘센트에 꽂혀
있어야 되는데
어디 있는지
파악이 안 됩니다
그래서 해당층이나
다른 위층 차단기함을 다 봤는데도
찾을 수가 없어서 이걸 또 시공하자로
그이 금액만큼 3분의 2 정도를
시공사에 또 청구했습니다
그래서이 비용도 조금 아꼈습니다
참고해서 그러니까 이거 하자 찾아내기
거의 이런
큰일이 있었을 경우에 현장을 가서
직접 보고
책임 소재를 나눠야 되는데 이런 걸
안 가고 업자한테만 맡기게 되면 이런
열선이 있었는데도 안 된 거를
모르니까
건물주분이 다 비용을 부담
했어야 될 수도 있는 상황이었습니다
그래서 저희는 열선도 하고 지금
보시면은 이렇게 만들었구나 틀을
만들고 저희가 덮개를 배관을 덮을 수
있는 덮개를 만들고 있습니다
그걸로는 또
충분하지 못하다고 생각해서 안에
보온재를 또 잔뜩 넣어서
겨울에 동파 예방을 할 예정입니다이
작업 때문에 현장을 방문했었는데
주차장에
등을 보시면은 이렇게 전등이 안
나오고 있습니다 모르시는
분이 보면은 등이 나갔다고 판단할
수도 있는데 이게
본인이 올라간 거 아니야 이거 예
맞습니다
[웃음]
업체분 오신 김에 사다리를 빌려서
잠깐 제가 작업을 했습니다
고쳤어요 이거 보시면 여긴 안
나오는데 지금 제가 만지고 또 나오고
있습니다 이렇게 아 이게 꽂아서
연결하는 방식입니다 제일 첫 단에만
전환이 들어오고
뒤에 쪽은 이렇게 연결을 해서
뒤쪽까지 전환이 공급되는 방식입니다
그리고 또 작업자 보는 기계 쪽이기
때문에 전기 쪽을 모르셔서 제가
요거를 또 작업하고 있습니다 전에
이제 이런 일을 했었잖아요 그죠네
맞습니다 전기 쪽 하신 거죠 일단
전기랑 승강기 쪽으로
5년 정도 일을 했습니다
현장에서
그러니까 이게 사실 저것도 사람
부르려면 다 돈이거든요 아무리
리모델링 현장이라서 뭐 무상으로
진행은 할 수 있지만
다른 오래된 건물 같은 경우에는 사람
뭐 부르게 되면 인건비만 최소 한
20 정도 기본으로 나오게 됩니다
이것도
제가 뚫었습니다
뚫었어요 저걸
그러니까 일단 기본 홈은 파져
있었는데 그거를 또 일자 드라이버랑
망치로 이렇게 툭툭 쳐가지고
완전히 뺄 수 있게끔
작업을 해서
여기로 이렇게 선을 아 이렇게 연결을
이렇게
돌아서 가게 되면은 선이 피복이
벗겨지면서 쇼트가 될 수 있기 때문에
이렇게 또 안전하게 이쪽 구멍을
이용했습니다
사실 이제 건물 관리라는게 저렇게까지
하는 경우는 거의 없거든
임차인이나 이렇게 비용 나간 거라든지
크게 보통
관리가 이제
문제 생겼을 때
막 처리하는 그 정도인데 이거는 거의
뭐
직접 다 하네요
일반적인 건물 관리하시는 분들
보시면은
연락이 왔을 때만
현장을 가서 아 연락이 오면 아
큰일이 터졌구나 생각을 하고
받으시더라구요 저희 같은 경우는 그냥
미리 예방을 하면서 또 작업도 어느
정도 가능하기 때문에 어느 정도
지식이 있기 때문에 좀 더 안전하게
예방할 수 있습니다
관리하면서 뭐 비용을 좀 줄였던 그런
사례를 좀 마지막으로 좀 보여주세요
자기가 관리하는 건물이
노후된 건물이라서
승강기가 설치된지 한 19년차가
됐습니다
이게 21년차가 되면
추가로 완전장치를 설치해야 되는데 그
비용이 2~3천만원이
됩니다
근데 이거를 보시면은 중소기업에서
기존 업체에서 견적 받은게
2,100만원입니다
근데 이거는 추가로 안전장치를
설치하기 때문에이 정도 금액은 필수로
발생하는 거고 저는 요런 거를 줄이는
방법을 알고 있기 때문에 제조사인데도
730만원에
작업을 진행하고 있습니다
엄청 많이 깎았네요
중소기업에서는 불가 안 돼 또
제조사에서는 가능한 거를 제가
어떤 부분이 가능한지 알고 있기
때문에 또 추가로 어떤 안전장치를
설치해야 되는지까지 다 알고 있기
때문에 이런
부분에서 비용을 크게 아낄 수가
있습니다
그리고 또 노후 승강기 같은 경우에는
OM 계약이라고 해서
월 보수로는 올라가지만 무상으로
부품을 교체해주는 그런게 있습니다
부품이 하나가 나가게 되면 엘리베이터
부품이 비싸기 때문에 최소한
300만원 이렇게 발생하게 되는데이
OM 계약을 하게 되면은
월 보수로는
조금 올라가긴 하는데 좀 많이 비싸긴
하지만 어차피
노후된
승강기고 여기 건물 같은 경우는
10년 동안 부품을 교체하는 내역이
없기 때문에 한번 나가게 되면
수백만원이 깨질 수 있는 상황이라서
내 계약도
월 보수로는 비싸지만 부품 교체
비용보다는
훨씬 저렴하기 때문에
그렇게 또 계약을 하고 있습니다
저건 확실히 그러니까 엘리베이터
전문가에서 그런 포인트들을 잘 안
쓰는 거 같아요
아 이거는 일단은 저희가 모바일로
원격 원격으로 해서
cctv를 확인할 수가 있습니다
근데 그거를
확인해 보니까 영업적인 확인했을 때는
8대가 설치되었다고 했는데
실제로 나오는 건 재개발이 안 나오고
있었습니다 세 개밖에 안 나왔어요
일단
4개는 아예 장비가 제대로 연결이 안
돼 있었고 하나는 지금 아예 그
도면에는
8대가 되어 있는데
실제 설치는 7대가 되어 있어서
요금은
8대 분 비용이 나가고 있었습니다
그래서 29개월
동안
CCTV 한 대가 미 설치된 부분에
대해서 비용을 28만원 환급받고
또 승강기 내부에
cctv가 누락된 거여서
많아서 또 승관계 업체 협조가
필요한데 또 협조를 하게 되면은
승강기업체에서 나와서 한두시간 정도
대기를 하고 있어야 되기 때문에
이것도 인건비가 발생하게 됩니다
근데 저는
노하우를 알고 있기 때문에 25만원을
그냥 무상으로 진행했습니다
그리고 또 제가 일부러
cctv를 보고 찾은 건 아닌데
정황상 아 이거 거짓으로
점검을 했을 것 같은데라고 판단해서
다 이미 파악을 하고
업체에 전화를 해서이 차 번호에
이렇게 생긴 사람 계시는지
확인하고
진짜로 1분만에 점검을 한 건지 다
상황을 확인하고 이렇게 반박 못하게
사전 파악 후 거짓으로 점검을 하게
되면 영업 정지랑 과태료랑 한
달만 이렇게 1분만에 점검했을 예는
없잖아요 그 사람의 습관이기 때문에
최소한 1년 정도는
그렇게 했다고 판단하고 그것도 환급을
하게 되면 또 100만원 정도 되기
때문에 이렇게 또 일을 크게 만들
수는 있었지만
그렇게까진 하지 않고
50만원 상당의 작업을 음성으로
긴장을 하고 점검을 똑바로 해줍니다
대박이다 1분만에 하고 가구나 그냥
이렇게 좀
긴장감을 줘야 자기가 잘못을 한 걸
알기 때문에 50만원 상당히 또
작업을 무상으로 진행했습니다
저도 이제 건물 관리 맡겨 봤지만
맡기고 난 다음에 이제 이런 새로운
것들을 알게 됐어요 저도 체크를 안
하고 있었어요 저렇게까지는
근데 저도 맡기면서 아 이런게
있었구나 아 내가 비용을 무리하게
납부하게
납부하고 있었구나 그거를 되게 알게
됐고 저는
진짜 자신있게 저희 그 bsn 그
빌딩 관리 팀은
정말 좀 그런 부분까지 잘
찾아
준다라고 저는 생각하거든요
저도 저도 느꼈으니까
내가 이게 놓치는게 많았구나 많이
놓치는 부분이 많았는데 저희 그 진짜
박종도 대리님 진짜
진짜 인재예요 내가 그래서 저희 그
박정도 대리님이
정말 꼼꼼하게 정말 시공사들이랑
업체들이
싫어할만큼
점검해서
세고 있는 돈들을 다 찾아 드릴테니까
언제든지
연락 주셔서 저희 박정도 대리님을
찾아주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 그래서
오늘 영상은 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다